good day to just hop on a cruise ship
and get acclimated what's that mean is
hungry again
you got a full-on plate there you can
snore a lot no okay
[Music]
what's up believe nation happy day to
sleep - in London we went to bed at
10:00 and will cover for us in six hours
that's not bad
Sun just came up here in London and we
are gonna do a little bit of London
exploring and then head off to our
cruise ship to continue our journey how
you feeling first we got to find you
some coffee
well you remain you not just me okay
I mean I'll drink some but you do
[Music]
Nina gets grumpy and so she has her
coffee so much we're gonna go fight here
we go
[Music]
Sun rising over England Big Ben
[Music]
we can't find Nina her Starbucks Oh
looks like it spread emoji
yeah oh wow t Nina's excited okay in we
go
put em on che there it is a breakfast
bagel cut the crusts off in two copies
how does it feel you got your coffee
I'm still finishing my coffee but I mean
I found something but a defining that
he's very excited she found her
Starbucks what are you gonna have
caramel popcorn what I wasn't gonna get
anything but definitely try that one
Starbucks here also has salad bowls
interesting how you feeling you know you
can just start by myself to finish mine
I saw that smile though we saw that
smile
[Music]
[Music]
do I want you to taste it for me uh yeah
yes I really want you to taste it for me
it's not like I have an option how was
it a lot look at the whipped cream oh it
was that little piece of puff time let's
give it a shot
oh it's good it's lighter than I thought
it has these dual trays I'm trying to
figure out if they actually made them do
oh they just ripped it in half what do
you think ripped it in half I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say they have a dual
because I want to discover something new
so it's wow look at this dual Wow Nina
we're here at the train station
gonna get our tickets and head off to
South Hampton and then we can head up on
bunch of our cruise
hook some dinners there get set up
I
buy tickets here we go we're all settled
in we mistaken layers off we've got a
nice table here let me do some work
you're gonna what are you gonna do
we're gonna chat you're gonna pass that
I mean it's probably gonna pass it
[Music]
we arrived at Southampton it's starting
to rain so good day to just hop on a
cruise ship and get acclimated grateful
for the awesome day we had yesterday
with no rain so we got to find the ship
hopefully doesn't rain too much get on
board
and come on guys how cute is Nina in our
hoodie how cute is that little creature
in our honey huh so cute we got our
cards
Nina's orange cuz she's new and there's
mine
oh I lost my wife let's go find her
there she is we're getting on the boat
and Nina is hustling and I'm having a
hard time keeping over there Nina is a
runner the camera shaking just trying to
catch up with you we need to do is book
our specialty
restaurant reservations because it gets
filled up super quick so run right to
the line
all right restaurants are booked next up
we got to get some internet get an
internet package so I can upload these
videos to Christina my editor and also
review the videos coming out next week
you guys still got to do my work make
sure we're bloating quality stuff and
then when we get some food right there's
nobody here though I don't get internet
where is the internet the manager is not
here until two o'clock so we're gonna
get get some food while we wait all
right
the feasting begins name a link to this
menu man you feel gross is only the
first day look at that all these
starters fruit and then
entrees burgers shrimp burger and a
pretzel bun with guacamole excited in
dessert we get dessert at lunchtime Nina
what do you think that doesn't exist in
Toronto
hey Nina how do you feel after your
first me on the boat and even had two
glasses of wine we were going 9196 on
this side I'm feeling super full
are you not full oh you didn't finish
your food though okay let's go see if
it's ready see if our room is ready
we're sneaking in early alright here's
our room here's our room welcome to nine
six oh eight our home for the next ten
days are you scared you have some
champagne
there's the balcony yeah right
happy times I don't know why this is on
now the drill I don't do the drill Nina
now execute the drill but really we need
to have CNN on where's CNN how was I
know CNN no information Bailey bridge
safety found NJTV Shore X on board Skye
CNBC BBC Sky News TV five prime there's
no CNN what are we gonna watch CNBC baby
Wow alright there we go there we go what
Nina yes okay what you're such an
alcoholic okay you already had two
glasses of wine and it's not even noon
yet okay so Nina wants me to film about
to show you guys so here we go okay
here's Nina got a room shower room
uh-huh
I'm very excited toilet different
doorway you're very excited about this
we got our internet for the week with
Nina's missing team oh it's only been a
day maybe two what's he doing do you
think he misses you yeah you think so
okay I think so too a lot I think he
really misses you
we're checking out the buffet just to
see you know there's any other options
that we missed might get a little
peckish
[Music]
looks like Nina's hungry again you got a
full-on plate there what is the head oh
so you nap too you're both hot stud woke
up boat was moving and now we're going
to dinner we ate slept and have to go
eat again
Nina's wearing a new dress this is
actually you showing your tummy well
it's a lot of food in that timing and
just about to get a lot more food in
there okay let's go eat
[Music]
Nina wants to throw up she's feeling
very full after her huge steak and
potatoes but she still wants to see the
desert retinue yeah
all right we'll see finish the dinner
feeling full how you doing
very full Nina grab another champagne on
the way out
and we're gonna go head up to the 12th
floor to see what the buffet has to
offer as soon as we get out Nina's like
go upstairs which means go to the buffet
so we'll see what else Nina orders huh
let's see if Nina only has warm water
becomes a reality check let's see what
happens what are we doing Nina watch the
show it's show time
[Music]
it's a video video I could shoot you
like this doesn't even look cute leave
me a comment if you think she likes cute
in the thumbs in the thumbs in the
comments we weren't allowed to film
copyright stuff but Nina was freaking
out the whole time
those tickets screaming yeah I never
forgot any joke but this one is the best
[Applause]
[Music]
you know I got us some more food forever
that's not all for me
I will have to win this favor for you
you may got somewhere alcohol to gonna
get more but they closed I'm just gonna
get more how many chinks do you need are
gonna bad it's 11 o'clock
you don't need more drinks well thank
you guys for joining us for date to
tomorrow we are off to Holland to have
another fun day with a friend
we'll see if Nina gets out of bed in the
morning all right thank you guys for
watching have an amazing weekend we
believe in you continue to believe
because it's important much love
whatever and whatever you want where is
we'll see you soon but we'll see we'll
see you soon bye